If you're new here,
you might be wondering what the contraption is on my countertop.
This is the spiral egg holder.
It beautifully displays the eggs we have here on our farm.
And it's also practical piece
as I have the eggs right there ready by the stove.
So let's jump it right into why I absolutely love this egg holder
and I've had it for four years.
Four years later and it's still perfect.
One of my favourite things about the spiral
is that it beautifully displays my eggs
while keeping them organised.
So I always know which one is the oldest egg in the bunch.
Always make sure that I have the oldest egg first.
So this egg goes in first
and then I'm gonna always take the egg from the bottom
and that way I always have the oldest egg so I don't get mixed up.
The orange link below to get yours today with free shipping.